The idea of absolute hot springs from its
better-known cousin, absolute zero, which,
as you may recall, is 0 K, -273.15° C or
-459.67° F. And although abridged definitions
of the lowest temperature will frequently
state it is the point at which matter stops
moving, this is technically incorrect.
Absolute zero is actually the point where
molecular motion no longer produces heat (but
does have zero-point energy).
Conversely, absolute hot, then, could be defined
as the point where molecular motion couldn’t
produce any more heat, no matter what the
circumstances.
In the Standard Model of the universe, the
hottest possible temperature ever reached
occurred a fraction of a second (10-43) after
the Big Bang.
During that minuscule period of time (called
one Planck time), the universe is thought
to have only been one tiny Planck length (10-35
meters) and have reached absolute hot at 1032
K (called Planck temperature).
For comparison, our Sun is a measly 1.571
x 107 K at its center and the highest temperature
ever created by man is currently 5.5 X 1012
K.
Beyond Planck temperature being the hottest
temperature ever theoretically reached in
our universe, physicists hypothesize that
at any temperature higher than Planck, the
gravitational forces of the affected particles
would become equally as strong as the other
fundamental forces (electromagnetic and weak
and strong nuclear), resulting in all four
becoming unified as one force.
What happens then?
Nobody knows as currently accepted conventional
models of physics break down after that point.
Of course, all of this is theoretical, since
no one has yet to come up with an accepted
quantum theory of gravity.
As Nobel laureate Steven Weinberg described
it, whatever happens at temperatures above
1032 K remains obscured by a “veil.”
It should be noted that not all physicists
follow the Standard Model, and some prefer,
for instance, String Theory, which attempts
to describe all four fundamental forces as
different manifestations of a single basic
object (a string).
For string theorists, the highest possible
temperature is far lower than that postulated
by the Standard Model; called the Hagedorn
temperature, it is the point at which ordinary
matter is no longer stable and either “evaporates”
or changes into quark matter.
Under this theory, the point at which that
happens, or absolute hot, is thought to be
just 1030 K, or about 1% Planck temperature.